[Music]
Gabe resumption create a worldview that
enables and justifies harassment and
terrorism this is what we're going to
talk about but it's going to be a long
road because I want to run through the
whole process from start to finish and
it gives us a great reason to talk about
critical tools this is actually a
subject that I've wanted to bring up
more often for a long time pretty much
since the show started but I've never
really gotten around to it I mean it's
been there in bits and pieces but let's
really crack into one because this is a
perfect time let's talk about base
assumptions base assumptions are the
things that you I everyone takes for
granted about the world they are the
things that default to yes or no until
proven otherwise
these are the things that we believe are
just the way things are in fact even
more than that they're often the things
that we don't even consciously believe
because they're frequently things were
completely oblivious to their invisible
unquestioned part of the background
believing is active you've encountered
something or being taught something and
thought about it and yes you think
that's how things work base assumptions
however are typically passive they're
just there as the rules that everything
else is built on they are one of the
major things that form what we consider
to be normal all right I know a bunch of
you are thinking well what is normal
maybe the crazy people are normal and
the normal people are the crazy ones and
that's good I've wondered the same thing
myself in the past it's wrong for a
variety of ontological reasons but it's
a good starting point because it's being
critical about assumptions that drive
daily life recognizing that many many
things in society are more or less
arbitrary constructs they may exist for
a reason but those reasons aren't
natural law take traffic lights for
example why are they red yellow and
green why not blue orange and hyper
violet
turns out the answer is pretty typical
back in the 1800s the railway industry
started using those colors and they just
kind of stuck red already has a history
as a warning signal Green was chosen
because it looks different from red and
yellow because it looks different from
the other two well as long as you aren't
colorblind that is right there we've hit
a base assumption the chosen colors
assume you
aren't colorblind so there are reasons
underpinning the choice of traffic light
colors there is a logic there but that
logic is arbitrary traffic light color
isn't dictated by the force of gravity
or the speed of light or some other
immutable fact it is a decision that
someone made over a century ago that
stuck because traffic rules need to be
more or less standardized so the drivers
know what to expect of others and what
others expect of them in order to
minimize how often they ram into one
another so that's a tiny example that
has nothing to do with narrative but
it's a good demonstration of how
something becomes just the way things
are let's apply the same to narrative
first things first we need to talk folk
AB you Larry kitchen vocabulary today's
kitchen vocabulary word is text now in
colloquial use text refers to the
printed word but here we're going to be
using it to refer to any cultural work
taken as a whole so a book the whole
book is a text as is a video game or a
movie or a song or an album or a TV show
or a video on the Internet the text of a
book includes the well text and any
pictures that happen to be included
while the text of a movie includes the
dialogue cinematography color palette
motion editing pacing and really any
other form of language that the movie
uses to convey meaning the text of a
video game includes all of that plus the
gameplay itself and the ludo narrative
created by the same because the
principles and theories that we're going
to be talking about apply more or less
uniformly to all of these different
media we're going to be using the word
text to refer to all of them at the same
time in order to evaluate the base
assumptions of a text it can be helpful
to anthropomorphize the text think about
it as though it were a person and figure
out what its priorities and beliefs
would be if you could talk to it this is
useful as a device because it can help
separate what exists in the text from
assumptions about the motives of the
people who made the text that's valuable
because while authorial intent can be
insightful or interesting in the end
only audience remains and it's entirely
possible for well-meaning people to
create problematic texts through
accident inattention or carelessness I'm
picking out an example that I touched on
ever so briefly before in my longer run
Man of Steel how does Man of Steel feel
about the military this council has been
disbanded military authority and Man of
Steel always goes on question when Zod
launches a coup attempt no one
criticizes his right to Authority
he is never stripped of rank he is never
accused of dereliction of the ethics and
morals of his position and he is never
challenged for his claim to leadership
something very very important to
remember before we go any further with
this is that every text is political by
nature as creators and audience we all
exist in a political context it is
inescapable even an attempt at creating
something a political is ultimately
political because it is a priori our
rejection of the political man of steel
which has some decidedly political
motives of its own is at the very basic
level and expensive consumer
entertainment product created in a
capitalist system it cannot help but
reflect that system push and pull off of
it any more than a swimmer in a pool can
avoid disturbing the water that is a
massive subject of its own if you want
to go deeper than you should start by
watching Slavoj X documentary a perverts
guide to ideology it's on Netflix back
to Man of Steel this uncritical opinion
of military authority is also reflected
in the human elements of the film and
drifts from underlying assumption up to
the surface Superman explicitly
condescends himself before the military
yes it's an ineffectual prostration but
that's basically the textbook definition
of a symbolic act it's a token effort a
small throw away that represents
something much larger in that act he
legitimizes their authority the
underlying assumption at play is that
the military is a legitimate locus of
power and that we as the citizenry
should defer to that power
it doesn't say as such but that is the
world of the text builds that is Man of
Steel's normal understanding that normal
being able to pull it out and look at it
is an invaluable skill in communications
opening up new and interesting meanings
and messages bridging gaps between
cultures that may seem to be at odds
revealing conflicts that were previously
invisible in paving the way for empathy
and understanding now we can talk about
gamergate there are some things that we
need
say about gamergate first this is not a
new phenomenon these ideas and beliefs
did not spring up in August 2014 with
gamergate any more than GG's most odious
ideologues or the women that they target
they were already here in this regard
gamergate score assumptions are not
unique but are reflective of attitudes
and opinions within society at large
attitudes that view the status quo as
the natural inevitable result of a
political forces Davis are reading
jordan owen john bain phil mason dean
Esme Polly lamb Jason Polara the
denizens of 4chan they already had an
axe to grind gamergate is nothing more
than the new name for a long-standing
resistance to the increased visibility
of minority voices in society at large
if we look at gamergate as a text look
at their message boards their IRC
channels their blog posts YouTube videos
claims priorities and target selection
we can drill down to the following base
assumptions about the world the
gamergate normal one there are no real
problems with inclusion or
representation in gaming - any problems
that do exist don't matter because
that's just market economics appealing
to the majority of players 3 the status
quo as they perceive it through the lens
of assumptions 1 & 2 is a natural state
thus any disruption is inherently
artificial this is the bedrock of the
movements ideology the core here is it
from their point of view the criticisms
directed at video games in the community
are fundamentally unnecessary that
nothing is wrong with the way things are
and that any problems are the
unavoidable result of natural processes
this is what drives the vitriol against
Anita sarkeesian zoe quinn brianna wu
and others they are seen as pretenders
if not invaders their criticism has
wholly out of place unnecessary and
artificial gamergate actively seeks to
have these voices silenced and expelled
from the industry this perception that
their natural state of normal is being
invaded feeds and internally justifies
the use of militaristic rhetoric
constant references to being at war and
organizing under names such as operation
Vox Populi and the hilariously named
operation shields of Silicon Valley the
use of harassment and abuse tactics such
as dogpiling sea lion and Gish galloping
and gaslighting are seen as acceptable
means justified by the ends where an
invaders are purged and the natural
state of normal is
stored the use of terror tactics such as
death threats daxing hacking and the
tacit threat of mobbing while engaged in
by the minority creates an environment
of fear that all members enjoy the
privilege of whether they engage in them
or not I'm going to restate that just
because of how important it has been in
the course of the last few months the
use of terror tactics even if only by a
minority has created an environment of
fear that all members enjoy the
privilege of when people are unwilling
to engage because they are afraid that
they'll be next that their websites will
be attacked that their information will
be stolen that their employers will be
harassed that they'll have child
pornography tweeted at them or sent to
their email all members benefit from
that person silence even if they were
not personally responsible for the
harassment one of the major ways that
gamergate enables harassment is through
its anonymous swarm mentality gamergate
at every turn
claims decentralization like being
attacked by a swarm of bees rarely does
any one person inflict a particularly
grievous wound each individual being
able to dispute their own involvement or
site the timidity of their contribution
this allows for perpetual deflection of
real harms because it is difficult to
summarize the cumulative impact of
hundreds of messages imply you are a
liar or obnoxiously asking for proof of
well proven facts additionally the swarm
is exploited by constantly claiming that
anything particularly bad is not the
work of a true gamer gator this is of
course a fallacy as by definition a
swarm has no one to dictate its overall
form thus no one to say what is or is
not a true gamer gator either everything
is in or everything is out even within
the more benign aims of the movement
these underlying assumptions are present
the primary target of corruption and
conspiracy accusations being women queer
folk and their allies particularly
insightful in this regard is gamergate
s-- use of code wording zoe quinn as a
persistent target of harassment to the
core of gamergate gamergate itself being
a hashtag coined by adam baldwin in
reference to the conspiracy videos was
eventually given the code name literally
who in an attempt at deflecting very
true accusations that the movement
largely revolved around demonizing and
punishing her it also serves as a
symbolic excommunication on ex parte
declaration of zoe as a non-person
stripping her of name and identity
however as additional Tarr
it's accrued the code name was expanded
to include dehumanize and expel others
barcoding each additional target as LW 1
LW 2 LW 3 and so forth
well no formal list was kept there were
at one point seven people codenamed as
literally who all women this list
eventually collapsed at the time of
publication having been produced 2 LW 1
through 3 zoe quinn anita sarkisian and
brianna wu the perception the base
assumption is that these women none of
whom are technically journalists
represent the invasion into the cultural
space an invasion of gender race
sexuality and class issues politics and
awareness they couch this idea in
conspiratorial tones assembling lists of
supposed collaborators and drawing out
complex webs of accusations implying
that these minorities are all Outsiders
looking to hijack games as a platform
for political ends this is of course all
other nonsense women queer folk trans
folk racial ethnic religious and
political minorities have been playing
games all along they have been here all
along they did not as 4chan summarized
with this image suddenly start playing
games in 2007 also as we've already
discussed games are and were already
political in nature because all culture
is unavoidably political what they see
as an invasion is little more than the
players who have been present all along
finding a voice in the market to discuss
politics that were already there this
fact along with the core assumptions
creates an interesting contradiction in
the companion hashtag not your shield
not your shield was conceived of as an
effort at creating a controlled counter
narrative something that's known as
culture jamming originally an
astroturfing campaign creating the
illusion of a grassroots movement the
hashtag gained traction beyond chanters
and sockpuppets the idea is that by
having minority allies the ideological
force of gamergate would be able to
deflect criticisms of their bigotry by
pointing to supporters and saying how
can I be racist if my best friend is
black you may notice that this is what
is often called using someone as a
shield before we can go deeper into the
issue we need to discuss more of gigi's
ideological roots gamergate spawned from
the 4chan boards VIII and pull and of
particular relevance to us is the gender
constructs held by those spaces
expressed with the mimetic idea of there
are no girls on the Internet tits or
gtfo
tits or gtfo is an enforcement mechanism
protecting the status quo the idea as
explained in a particularly popular post
is that due to the anonymous nature of
most interactions over the internet no
one will know if you're a woman unless
you specifically mention it moreover
even if you claim you're a woman you
have to prove it hence tits or gtfo
well 4chan interprets this as everyone
is anonymous a more accurate reading is
everyone is default until proven
otherwise
by retaining anonymity you enjoy the
protections inherent to membership in
the majority this is obviously of some
appeals individuals who are otherwise
marginalised the only cost is the
annihilation of one's own identity or at
least a willingness to subsume those
aspects that are out of harmony with the
gamergate normal gamer gates ideal woman
is one who is passive conventionally
attractive and generally voiceless this
is actually a provable point because
gamergate has provided us with their
ideal woman in the form of mascot
Vivienne James really this is opening up
a rabbit hole all its own I could go on
for hours about the semiotics of this
character and how she's represented in
the myriad comics that have been made
featuring her but the crux of it is that
she's an expression of the ideal
emergent from the base assumptions of
their worldview their ideal woman is one
who never imposes herself or her
identity into the shared space if she
were on the other end of a game you'd
never even know she wasn't a dude this
ties directly into conflicts that arose
repeatedly within the notyourshield
hashtag as gamergate ideologues turned
on and excommunicated individuals who
criticize sexism homophobia transphobia
and racism within the movement the
message was loud and clear minorities
are welcome as long as they leave their
identity at the door the perception of
diversity is incredibly valuable
specifically because it could function
as a shield to jam criticism but the
exercising of that diversity still have
to conform with the base assumptions
nothing is wrong with the way things are
to insist otherwise is to become an
invader now to go deeper into that why
is it so important for Anita sarkeesian
at all to be invaders the reason is in
assumption number two any problems in
the industry are the natural result of
market forces much of gamergate has
revolved around game reviews in the Khan
10th there in namely the reviewers
political ideologies impacting the
review this is critical because
gamergate accepts reviews as sacred
within their construct the free market
is the arbiter of culture the status quo
exists because the market is responding
to the normal so much of their identity
as gamers is tied up in materialism
never mind that it is a consumer
demographic an artificial construct of
marketing think tanks looking to
maximize user investment in a retention
by crafting a narrative the spotlights
the customers unique member of an
exclusive club based largely on a shared
fiction that aspect isn't considered a
negative because it already conforms
with their politics the culture of
gaming is a culture of ownership and the
priests of that culture are the
reviewers who tell them what to buy this
is why gamergate seeks to purge all
conflicting ideologies and demographics
because the free market is their God if
Anita sarkeesian isn't an invader then
she is a customer just like them and has
equal right of access to the market
games changing to include more diversity
is painted as capitulating to outsiders
because it otherwise means that the
market is simply catering to new
customers the reviewers who disagree
with them or hold alternate views on
politics must be invaders because
otherwise it means that there are other
customers being served which demolishes
the gamergate normal a common sentiment
passed around is the gaming sites that
entertain discussions about misogyny
gender presentation sexual identity and
propagandistic motives underlying
partnerships with Armed Forces are
alienating their customers the belief is
if I'm not their customer then who is
gamergate at its core does not believe
that anyone outside the normal has an
authentic interest in video games this
is a coarse hogwash the outrage the
histrionics are wholly unmerited if not
entirely illegitimate however however
that anger is still felt authentically
even if it is not legitimate even though
the proximal justifications for their
actions have been routinely demonstrated
to be false either because they are
route misinterpretation or even total
fabrication by opportunistic ideologues
the sense of hurt of violation and
marginalization the sense that their
space is being invaded isn't fake the
motivators are not true most all of the
people who they have accused of ethical
violations have proven to be exemplars
the Byzantine can
yura seas have been exposed as flim-flam
but the sense of hurt he is real and
this is how gamergate s---based
assumptions create a worldview that
enables and justifies harassment and
terrorism it indoctrinates them to
believe that they are under assault the
games don't need criticism that
criticism is unwelcome inappropriate
misplaced or useless it tells them that
everything is fine
it takes an authentic hurt and target
sitted imaginary thieves it takes
vulnerable people with authentic pain
and points them at women at queer folk
at trans folk and tells them they are
trying to take your stuff because the
underlying motivations are ultimately
the protection of an aggressive
isolationist status quo any support
becomes support in the service of those
assumptions it is supportive a worldview
where the marginalized are unwelcome
unless they first obliterate themselves
on the altar of the normal it is a
worldview that demands conformity and
will aggressively shout down harass
abuse and exile those who resist this is
really just scratching the surface of
all of this as I said earlier gamergate
is really a microcosm of larger societal
issues and as such it reaches out and
touches many subjects that I haven't
even had room to reference in this
episode such as masculine identity the
formation of subcultures the process of
indoctrination the adoption of cultural
jargon the implications of gamergate
ceman to litter eyes deviation the fact
that while claiming to reject
politicization there are reactionary
ideologues actively politicizing GG
supporters for their own ends the at
best shaky understanding of ethics and
so on and so on and so on but I hope I
hope that this exercise has been
illustrative of the value of critical
tools beyond simply picking apart movies
and games
you
[Music]